what if it's true I mean what if and so
I started investigating it and then it
was yeah like basically no-brainer and
then you're convinced the Earth is flat
oh 100 really 100 no doubt whatsoever
all right so 100 where do we start with
this
um
I mean
planets are round you look at all the
planets the other planets we'll plant
Planet the term Planet actually means
moving star
that's that's that's where we came up
with the term Planet so we are and I
don't definitely don't think we are a
planet we are a plane a plane of
existence So when you say Planet like in
the old times or hundreds of years ago
and thousands of years ago they've
always said planets were those stars
that move
so there's seven eight nine I think
they're nine now but anyway
um Jupiter Saturn and all that and
but to our eyes they are they look just
like all the other stars they just
happen to be the ones that move so
that's that's where we came up with that
certain Planet but Saturn Mars Pluto
they're all the enormous mass and the
gravity that's involved that's what our
science is made them round right our
science says that they're around like
they okay so let me say it like this
conceptually they're a ball but to our
eyes they're just a circle it's just
like the Sun and the Moon I believe
they're all the same and I definitely
don't think that the plant those planets
those moving stars that we're talking
about Jupiter Mars Saturn Etc
um though they all have their own lights
they all have their own energy they're
not reflecting the Sun's light just like
I don't believe the the moon Moon's
light is not the Sun's light a lot of
people think that but just because
science taught you that but it's the
light of the moon comes from in its own
light yeah it's its own light it's
internal it's whatever we don't know
where I don't know that's what I would
like to investigate those are the types
of questions I'd really like to look
into but there are times the night where
the half half the Moon is dark for
example it's exactly well this is a
there's a there's an LED program that
makes it you know turn on the certain
parts of the Moon exactly I'd like to
yeah let's start with the moon then
right right there it's um this is some
of the things about the Moon that are
really fascinating
um and to prove to show you that they're
not reflecting the Sun's light is for
about three weeks every month so 75 of
the time you can look up in the sky
during the day and see the moon up there
with the Sun at the same time it's never
full when it's up in the sky when we see
it during the day never the only time
it's full is when the sun is set and
then the Moon
when it's on the other side of the
planet is the only time you ever see the
moonfall ever okay so in other words you
never see the moon full have the same
reflected reflecting the Sun's light
ever at the same time but you see the
moon Waxing and waning in whatever
paragraph either it's Waxing or Waning
all the time and and during that day
like say it's a a quarter moon
and it's in the sky with the Sun the
sun's moving the moon's moving a little
bit you know everything's moving and it
never changes its its peregrity the the
you know it's if it's quarter moon it
stays a quarter moon in other words
that's one little hint to show you that
the the sun is not reflect or that's not
reflecting the Sun the moon's not
reflecting the sun okay that's one
little hint
just some the simple fact that we get to
see in the Sun and see it in the sky
with the sun and the sun is not
affecting it through that entire day
even if it just happens every once in a
while but it happens every freaking day
that it's up there that we see them
together that's the way it is it never
changes so if this whatever the Moon is
that's what it stays through that whole
day and into the night
um and then you can also at night time
when the moon is full you can pull out a
thermometer and put it out in the light
of the moon right
um and let's say let's say that as an
example the thermometer reads 70 degrees
in the full Moonlight if I put in the
shade of the of the Moonlight it
actually gets warmer
and I pull it out it gets colder again
so the moon's light is cold it's not
it's not hot so it's not reflecting the
sun it has nothing to do with the sun
that's what I mean by it's its own light
and that's a simple scientific
experiment anybody can do it thermometer
um I don't know if you've ever done it
but I've I've lived in the northern
climates before and a lot of times if I
park my car under a tree I'll come out
to my windshield to my car in the
morning and half of my windshield will
be Frozen and the other half won't be
it's happened many many times and I
never really thought about it until a
few years ago and I put it all together
I'm like wow
the reason it frosted over is because
that the full moon light hit that part
of the windshield and this part was
underneath the tree in the shade
so I I could I could pop your bubble a
little bit but I'm not going okay I'm
not going to the so when you go to the
social Gatherings parties whatever do
you
Avatar do you strike up a conversation
where you start talking about the Earth
being flat absolutely I've been talking
about everything yeah basically ever
since I found out the Earth is flat I
was like okay I gotta tell everybody
what is the typical reaction
um usually people are it's either it's
very divisive right off the bat it's
people are either like what tell me more
or and they walk away you know like just
laugh at me
um
and I don't mind I don't I I'm not
trying to convince anybody like of any
one of my things that I believe or
research I'm not so much like you got to
believe like I believe it's more like
hey here's just a few hints you know
that maybe everything's not the way you
we we've been taught maybe it's not the
way you think
you know and I feel like if if I can
just get my brothers and sisters to open
their eyes a little bit start looking
outside the box
um
we can move with more freedom and more
power
a lot of times the I feel like that's
kind of what's been being repressed is
our truth the truth of us is our power
so if our if we believe a lot of false
things then we're going to be going down
rabbit holes that
you know I think that's the part big
part of the problem right now in our
society is just the simple fact that a
lot of people are believing lies just
complete deception
um here's another one just kind of jump
off on the moon the Sun for example
from our perspective the moon and the
sun are the same size from our
perspective but they tell us science
starts to tell us that we're going
around the sun and the moon's going
around us
it looks like and from again from our
experience it looks like the sun and the
moon are different they're the exact
same size
um they have power we can feel their
power like if you believe in astrology
at all at all like all of our ancestors
have always believed it they believe
that the Sun the moon and all the star
each of the individual stars have their
own power they have their own
potency that they're putting affecting
us so like if you're born on a
particular day of the year you that's
you know if okay that's your sun sign
you're a Gemini and then the exact day
that you're born will know okay that's
where the moon was in the sky and then
they can take a picture of the entire
Sky they know exactly where all the
planets were the moment you were born
and that's going to impact your entire
life yeah I mean do you enjoy being this
controversial person at a gathering
where you're you're like
um proposing these theories that are I
put it this way brother I never before I
learned that Earth was flat I was not a
divisive person and at least not in the
sense of I was questioning things but I
wasn't like yeah definitely out of party
like the example
are there other theories that are
since I found out the Earth was flat
Then I then it basically it unwrapped
everything like oh my gosh if if that's
true was the moon landing uh a complete
Force yeah in 911
planned totally purposely planned
absolutely what other theories do you do
you
um I believe that we that
well 500 years ago we've
found your the new world I don't believe
it was the new world this is an Old
World
um
and all and it's easy to figure that out
um some of the hints are when any of the
Europeans got here in the first
Europeans they got here they weren't
talking about Savage tribes they were
talking about huge cities the every
river they went up from the bay they'd
go up different Rivers South America
Central America North America and the
the banks would be lined with people and
big giant beautiful cities I believe
that when the Europeans got to what they
call the new world it was already
populated and the cities were there like
for example we have the same
architecture in New York as you do in
London and everywhere around the world
the same thing happens in New Zealand
Australia same kind of architecture same
buildings these massive beautiful
cathedrals
um I I do some construction and the the
buildings that these people built are so
amazing so gorgeous you know it's the
best it's like our what we when we go to
Europe there are castles and Cathedrals
and with wow these roofs are like you
know huge crazy pitches that would be
hard for us to present day to put on
even with all of our equipment with
everything and and yet we say oh these
people weren't as advanced as we were
I feel like these people were definitely
more advanced uh like for example 500
years ago
just in English everything got changed
we got a new calendar we got a new Bible
so religion
um time and religion boom changed I
think English was just coming out like
really getting popular because that's or
at least that's the best English we have
is
um Shakespeare still our best poet 500
years ago really and yet we're still
being told that we've evolved or that we
are evolving do you believe that humans
evolved from
apes and stuff like that no because no
only and I say that because
um we're humans just it's too beautiful
it's too perfect it's too amazing this
this world is has to have been created
there's too many details that are
perfectly in synchronizations perfect
you know you take one little molecule
out and it screws everything up
everything everything dies you add one
thing poison you know but the way it is
it's orderly it's perfect it's balanced
it always finds its own balance it keeps
coming back to itself
um and yeah to have something that
perfect I think had to be created I
don't know who the Creator was who the
God was
um
but is very it is very intelligently
designed and the smartest people that I
know like the the scientists that are
doing like physics and Quantum really
questioning reality and really going
down to things that they can't even talk
about the stuff that they're doing in
everyday life most people wouldn't even
understand them
um but they're all saying the same
things like the more we learn the more
we realize this is like people are
nowadays calling it a simulation for
example like this is too perfect it's
like it's almost like it's a computer
program or something wow
uh yeah so I I believe that everything
was taken away from us maybe 500 years
ago there might I I'm I'm just going to
say some weird things I feel like
um
we might have had a more beautiful
civilization like I'll say something
really weird it looks like the Jesus
that we celebrate for modern day
Christianity
um it looks like that it that happened
more like a thousand years ago 1500
years ago and then there was a thousand
years of peace
that's what it looks like as far as like
art when I say looks like is the history
of our ancestors not Modern Day history
but we we if we listen to what our
ancestors talk about that's what it says
and then you just look at the
architecture like as mentioning that a
minute ago there's these beautiful
cathedrals and and roofs that are
steeped and and just the design of the
concrete it looks like the same people
built the same things all around the
world and in Europe they oh that was
built a thousand years ago but in the
new world oh that was built 100 years
ago what about New Zealand yeah 100
years ago oh so all Mexico is like
Mexico's aqueducts for example Mexico
has more aqueducts than Rome
you know nothing even competed with Rome
until Mexico well then who did Mexico
was it the missionaries or the the
Conquistadors you know like who did it
and when I say Aqueduct it means like
you're taking water from one place
moving at 100 or 300 miles away and
you're crossing over rivers and valleys
to get there you know so it's a huge
huge undertaking
but that's what you see in Mexico
um so I feel like that's the
put it this way let me say it like go
back to the Thousand-Year thing in the
Bible it was predicted there's a
thousand years of peace
and then Christ would let Satan back out
of his
um out of the jail or whatever you put
him in and that's what it looks like
happened it looks like there was a
thousand years of peace all around the
world now
and I'm not saying like one culture one
language necessarily but definitely the
the again the same architecture
everywhere
um the same beliefs too even though
there's different languages we all of
our ancestors say the same kinds of
things when I say ancestors I'm talking
about like the Mayans and Inca and you
know Japan China Russia basically
anywhere around the world you go to and
they're going to tell you the same
basic stories you know there was a flood
there was a creation there was Gods
coming down people coming down helping
people other humans and advancing like
some some demi-gods maybe or Gods but
they taught him language math
jewelry making how to work metal Etc
that's what they all say and then
there's also a flood
they all say that you know and yet
nowadays scientists oh that didn't
happen that didn't happen but it's only
been in the last hundred years that
they're even teaching people that the
world is a globe it was a hypothesis a
theory 500 years ago but even 100 years
ago nobody thought the world was a globe
and we're not spinning
they we're told that it's been around
for 500 years and everybody knows that
they're flat Earth really well then why
does the military and even during World
War II I don't know if they probably
they have to nowadays there's no such
thing as as like if you have a globe and
I want to go from one place to another
on the globe
um why would I use flat plane
trigonometry to get there
unless we're on a flat plane you know on
a globe navigation doesn't work
um on a flat plane of existence
everything makes sense if basically all
of our Mysteries all over the things
that were wow what's up with that it all
makes sense on a flat plane the the moon
I like to do the moon because even
modern-day scientists have no understand
like the moon does not fit in with
anything else that they've talked about
you know they're oh yeah these planets
do so the sun's this the nurse this and
blah blah blah
it's weird the moon has these weird
things about it I mean there's like
literally like 100 things about the Moon
that literally don't fit is the moon
flat as well well here's some more
things about the Moon from our
perspective some of the things that we
notice about the Moon is that there are
craters on the moon like when let's say
it's full okay we're looking at the moon
it's full
middle of the night we're looking up all
the craters on the moon are perfect
circles so there's not asteroids hitting
at an angle you know they're they looks
more like lightning bolts maybe
um and we see the same thing on on on
our Earth on our flat plane that when
anytime we see craters they we're we're
told an asteroid hit that you know ah oh
really why are they predominantly all
over Death Valley for example in
California we have asteroid impact zones
everywhere hmm
Nevada Utah
like the places that we are now deserts
but then if you look at really close and
I'm talking like look at it from Google
Earth you'll see Foundation marks like
old buildings they're all rectangles and
squares and stuff
in other words it looks more like the
City was destroyed with with
Direct Energy some kind of energy
weapons all of those craters were
circles there's never a rock in any of
these craters it's not like an asteroid
if we are a ball spinning these
asteroids would be hitting us at an
angle and they'd be carving furrows
through the ground that doesn't happen
all we have is perfect circles with no
rocks in them so I'm proposing that
um
yeah again we're not a flat plane
there's some things and it looks like a
direct energy of some kind I have a lot
of a lot of questions I don't definitely
don't have all the answers I'm trying to
trying to have all the answers but I'm
trying to raise up more questions what
was your childhood like what was my
childhood like how'd you grow up
um where'd you grow up I grew up in the
mountains above Fresno so I was Mountain
boy I lived in Fresno for a while too
Clovis so in the middle of California
um my parents were Christian so I was a
Christian growing up
um Pentecostal and Baptist
um went to
played football through school college
um got out married married when I was
24 I think
I have five kids
um I'm a landscape designer contractor
for most of that's how I made my money
supporting the family I've always been a
body worker also a massage therapist
um
good childhood though my childhood
itself yeah it was it was good good for
the most part
um I got what was your relationship like
with your dad
um my dad and I were really good friends
like we got along really good I love my
dad I still love my dad a lot but it
wasn't
um
I guess I would say that things be
my parents both worked a lot let's just
say it like that they were both very
busy so I had a lot of free time when I
was a teenager
um I got molested I had my doctor and my
my martial arts instructor and my doctor
lived together
it was my first introduction to
um gay lifestyle being being with men
had never even considered that got
molested and so I think that that
impacted me more than anything else like
if I think back on my childhood I still
think of that like that's the thing that
impacted and changed a lot I got
introduced to basically the dark side I
always thought everything was beautiful
wonderful and cool and light and you
know if I heard stories about people
being mean to each other didn't really
believe it like how could anybody
actually be mean to each other
um but then I got to see that I got to
see the Shady Side and the excuses and
how somebody could like he didn't think
he was doing anything wrong you know but
it hurt me terribly yeah it's horrible
how often that happens in our world yeah
exactly and if and if you're a boy in
this world in this Society there's like
it's it's even worse than being a girl
you know like if a girl gets raped like
she it's really hard for her to come out
and say that to tell anybody you know
she feels ashamed all these reasons but
it's almost impossible for a boy to say
that even you know in other words it's
even more difficult it probably stays in
stays secret exactly with men as an
adult I do this I do therapy a lot I do
I'm an intimate intimacy coach and and
massage therapists so I have been
dealing with this a lot and most of my
focus is with men because of my own
struggles and then thing I started doing
it for a long time ago and at first I
was doing it just to make a little extra
money doing things to help other people
do what I was going through but I was
using these
therapy sessions for my own healing as
well you know I was like just turn
around and get hey I'll help you and
help me back
um
and now
uh I forgot where I was going with that
I can edit this out too okay it was um
intro yeah it's interesting you start
thinking about my childhood I'm like
that threw me for a loop
um
go back to Flat Earth
no I mean a child is a big impact on who
becomes adult as adults isn't it yeah
was there ever any
kind of
misrepresentation of the truth in your
childhood or you know your dad would
like your dad was straightforward and
communicated clearly with you
whatever the things that just weren't
said or things that you had to figure
out exactly I think there's a lot of
things that just weren't said that I had
to figure out I've I started thinking
that like my parent for example here's a
good example my parents my grandparents
every my pastor everybody would say
don't lie don't lie don't lie you know
that's horrible don't lie and yet I
would find everybody lying right like
all the adults around me I'm like that's
what I'm talking about yeah like you
guys are full of like and you all
say that you're not foolish so it makes
you question the truth 100 so I exactly
so I'm questioning truth on everything
that by the time I get a little older
yeah by the time I'm 15 16 I'm starting
to think that everybody lies no one's
telling the truth and the only way to
work through this Maze of existence is
to get better at lying you know be good
at it because everybody else seems to be
really good at it and pretend like
they're not lying and now as an adult
you become a conspiracy theorist I guess
yeah I guess so that is interesting huh
for sure it it it it made me the way I
am for sure it really and yeah yeah
that's true it's a really good point
when you're at a gathering group of
people whatever party and and this comes
out what's your I understand what the
other people's reaction is there you got
a lot of eye rolls and things like that
what is your reaction to all that well I
don't really mind at all at all because
I don't feel like it's my opinion I
literally feel like it's the truth the
Earth is freaking flat you guys and
there's no doubt about it like zeroed
out people a lot of people come to me
well you can't really know and I'm like
actually I can no you know in other
words I've studied this enough
and the truth is blatant like the the
actuality of things are blatant you're
100 convinced it requires a lot of faith
to believe that Earth is a globe like a
lot of faith most people don't think of
that because the scientists told him and
we're not faith-based you know this is
actually I just wonder if if in fact the
Earth was flat you might be somebody who
was trying to
convince everyone that it's round
not this well you you just put it put it
this way though again I'm I'm not gonna
well I wouldn't never feel comfortable
I'm not just pushing buttons to push
buttons although sometimes I do that so
I guess that is part of me for sure
um but no I don't like to do things I
wouldn't say anything especially into
groups or like on camera unless I felt
like I'm speaking the truth in other
words I'm not sitting there just
bullshitting to
fire people up in any way
um I for example
scientifically
and there's a lot of things in science
that people think oh if if a scientist
told me it must be true well almost
everything that they teach you are
theories okay like literally there's
hardly any actual laws scientific laws
and when they say it's a law that means
it's like 99.9 it's at least 99 sure in
other words every time in the laboratory
when we test this it looks like this
this always happens
for example in the laboratory water
always finds its own level this what's
what water does you know almost
everything in science there's like 100
laws
like there's really not that many actual
scientific laws but almost all of them
are about water and around water the
actual laws because we can test it prove
it shown every time so a few of them for
example it always freezes at 32 degrees
right in this atmosphere that's when it
freezes not 30 not 33. 33 it won't even
start icing up 32 boom it starts icing
up
211 degrees
nothing as soon as it hits 212 boom it
starts boiling
these are laws okay that you can know
this depend on it trust it well another
one is water always seeks its own level
it seeks the path of least resistance
so that's why we have Rivers that's why
the rivers always come down to sea level
that's why we have a horizon
so if I'm standing on the beach I can
look at the Horizon and Horizon by the
way is short for horizontal line okay
it's not just some made up word it's
Horizon
went from the beach you can actually get
a level and test this test my theory
you'll never ever ever see a curve on
the horizon ever I don't care even if
you go high
here's two things that happen when you
go High by the way if I'm well let me
start off I'm at the beach I look across
the Horizon and when I'm in Hawaii I do
this all the time to people but you can
see an island right over there okay it's
20 miles away they tell us 17 to 20
miles away like whether you're on the
big island looking at Maui or you're on
Kauai looking at Nihao they're meeting
about they're about 17 to 20 miles apart
distance and you when when you're on the
beach you can see the other Island the
entire Island you know and maybe you
can't see the beach because there's some
waves and there's a little distance and
maybe obscure but if I climb this tree
10 feet up I can see the other Island 20
miles away the beach and everything the
whole thing and if I climb that mountain
right behind me say it's 300 feet 400
500 feet up not only can I see that
whole island I can see the other side of
the island and I can see another 20
miles like that same distance between of
Ocean between me and Island right now
when I get that high I can see that same
distance on the other side of the island
so I'm looking way past in the Horizon
this is the other key point
the main key points is water is always
level and the Horizon always meets your
eye like if I could say nothing else
about Flat Earth those are two my two
main points if water is always always
level and it's a law then at what point
does anybody start thinking that it's
curving you know if we're on a ball
then science would tell you how big the
ball is because they know how big how
big we are they're going to tell you
exactly what the curvature rate is
and then right there you know they're
lying why do you think so many people
have it wrong
um the my only answer to that is that
it's a purposeful deception
um but what is the the goal of it the
goal is to keep us entrapped to keep us
enslaved to keep our in the slavery of
our mind that's that's really what it's
all about so if if I for example if I if
you believe what you experience if you
believe your own experience you would do
what I do you look out you see the
horizon line you could climb up this
mountain you still see the horizon line
and the horizon line always meets your
eye if I'm in an airplane I fly 10 000
feet up guess what I look out horizon
line meets my eye it means like it's
wonderful when you're taking off from
Hawaii you're coming out off the island
as soon as you get up in there I mean
you're a couple hundred feet up you look
up you can see the entire Island I mean
literally the whole thing and then the
Ocean Way Beyond that and you keep
getting higher and higher the horizon
line always meets your eye which means
that you're seeing further and further
and further so not only is the line flat
level this way the horizon line not only
is that what we experience like
sometimes people say well sometimes I'm
in a plane and I can see a little curve
and now you can't that's the maybe you
can it looks like that but it's just the
curvature of the window there's three
three Windows between between you and
and that the outside one's flat the
inside one's flat and then there's a
curved one in there to keep the pressure
and that's gives you that that cat the
uh what's it called
where you see more anyway it makes it
look like there's a little bit of curve
you're not you're an educated man but
the fact is you've graduated high school
of course oh yeah yeah in college yeah
yeah yeah you seem very intelligent but
the the curvature this way so a lot of
people are like oh maybe there's a
little bit of curvature this way okay
same thing like if you look at the
pictures any of the space pictures there
oh look we're at the Hubble telescope or
we're at this you know we're looking
down we're at the space the shuttle
going around
with this what you'll see you'll always
see the Earth and like like these big
huge you know looks like this giant like
like it is a ball all right they make it
look like it's a ball but what you see
also is that that the highest point of
that curve
literally no whether it's tilted this
way or that way no matter how they tilt
the camera the main Apex of that curve
is always right at eye level
so it's showing like literally all
science I mean all the space all those
shuttle guys in space astronauts Astro
not are never looking down at a ball
and the the guys that did the moon
landing they said they did a little moon
landing if you look at that you take the
they have a pictures and of
the Earth from the Moon the problem with
that picture is that the Earth is the
same size as the Moon from our
perspective so like
from the Moon if they were looking back
at the Earth Earth would be very big but
they make the Earth the same size as
what we see the moon like in relative
distance you know our relative size with
all the history and imagery that we have
you think there'd be some glaring
blatant example that's my point like if
you
fat bro that's exactly where I'm at I'm
like if you guys believe in a globe
please show me a few pieces of evidence
just just you just even one show me one
that's convinced me I'm not because I'm
not here to prove you wrong but I'm
going to I'm going to ask you a question
or two sure sure just because somebody's
gonna get frustrated if I don't 100 so
if the Earth is flat at some point if
you took a boat to the edge of this flat
plane
somebody what happened somebody would
say hey look at this yeah yeah well
that's a great question or a great point
so check this out I believe that the
Earth is flat like I said the center of
our plane of existence is the North Pole
okay literally if so if you that's why
all of the compasses Point North doesn't
matter how far south you go all
compasses Point North in other words we
don't have a South Pole there's nothing
magnetic down in the South Antarctica
okay ever nothing all compasses Point
North that's because we have a lodestone
our ancestors say there's a giant tree
or a Giant Mountain mountain all these
different words different cultures say
different things but it's always a
magnetic point up there
and the North Star is the one star in
the sky that doesn't move well it turns
out it's directly above our North Pole
so it's as if you know it's like a giant
what they call it terrarium or whatever
and it's just spinning so if you go to
the North Pole and you do slow motion
photography all the stars are spinning
in circles
literally perfect circles around you so
we're rotating around the earth uh the
sun of the sun exactly I'm proposing to
you that the sun and the moon are moving
around us just like it looks like they
are the same size not 400 miles further
bigger and 400 times further apart yeah
it's very much the same the Sun and and
astrologically speaking I think the moon
has just as much of an impact as the sun
on us one is our conscious side one's
our unconscious side one's gold one
silver one's hot one's cold
um oh let me say this point on that also
if you put food out
in the sun it gets dehydrated if I put
food out in the full Moonlight it gets
putrified it putrefies really fast so it
rots it's just it's exactly opposite
um they the all of our answers said the
sun is masculine if the moon's feminine
and I may just go on and on and on
and it makes sense like if if you see
the world like that everything starts
clicking like all these weird questions
that we have from our normal from our
perspective from our society are all
basically they're all science questions
they're like well if we this and that
then hmm and then you come up with all
these weird questions but if you just
see the Earth as simple
that's how I see it's just very simple
um basically what it boils down to is
the sun is not the center of our galaxy
we are the Sun and the Moon all the
planets are revolving around us and not
just us as a whole but I like to tell
people like your mom and dad told you
the world doesn't revolve around you and
I like to tell them yeah it does
actually it totally revolves around you
whatever you think and believe is the
world that you're going to have you're
literally your thoughts your perspective
the things you expect
happen you know we live in a magical
Universe
um another example of that kind of
jumping around but another example of
that is
um I like to share this with anybody
because I think everybody's gone through
this experienced this you can be in a
crowd of people and suddenly you feel
like somebody's looking at me and you
can just turn and find the person that's
looking at you right away without even
look you don't look have to look around
they can have glasses on you don't have
to see their eyes you can tell who's
looking at you and what you can even
feel what they're thinking a lot of
times people walk into a room
the whole energy changes you know or
somebody walks out of the room energy
changes dramatically
um I I've been around really that
doesn't mean the Earth is flat though no
not at all all no no again I'm not
trying to I don't have to convince
anybody the Earth is flat they went but
it when when you understand the Earth is
flat then sure starts opening up all the
other oh yeah basically you're like oh
there are different perceptions or
sensory things that are probably going
on with humans that we don't realize
exactly some of us do but exactly
exactly let me ask you one more question
sure to debunk your theory um
so if the Earth is a flat plane why is
why is it the sunrise in Europe 10 like
eight to ten hours before it does in the
U.S so what's happening is the Sun is
going like see this is the North Pole
the sun is traveling around like that
okay in the summertime in the northern
hemisphere it's summertime when this
when the sun gets closer to the North
Pole and so here's another good point
and then when it hits the Tropic of
Cancer
the north I think that's the north yeah
that's the north one
the sun stops right there at the trop of
cancer that's what the Tropic of Cancer
is by the way people most people don't
even know what the traffic cancer is the
tropical Capricorn they don't even know
what it is they are those two lines are
the Divination or the mid or the end
the fence the end of the sun the sun
does never goes any further than the
tropical Capricorn never goes further
north okay so as it's getting to that's
our summer time
right at the top the height of Summer
June whatever June 26 or something it
hits that's when the Sun hits the Tropic
cancer and then it goes back the other
way it starts heading back towards drop
of Capricorn
and by the time it gets back there again
that's what we call here from from one
to the next is six months it takes 180
days to go from one to the other one
okay from Tropic cancer to the tropical
Capricorn when it hits a line of
tropical Capricorn it literally stops
again and switches directions again we
call that one year when it goes from one
there and back again when it hits again
that's one full year
um
check this out though this is wonderful
we don't have 12 months in a year we
have 13 there are 13 moons in a 364 a
day cycle and if they're all at 28 just
hypothetically let's just say that they
are I think they are there's actually 13
moons 13 times 28 is 364.
we would have a very simple basic
calendar if we had one zero day just
like the Mayan calendar did my my
calendar the reason it's so amazing is
they were looking at five thousand years
they didn't just take one year and make
a calendar they did a 5 000 year
calendar and every single day
in that five thousand years has its own
flavor their own characteristics it's
like Wheels within Wheels to determine
what that day is going to be flavored
like in other words this wheel that will
and this will spinning
will determine how which planets are
affecting how they're reflecting where
they're at when they're and that gives
the energy say of that particular day
and they can predict that way ahead of
time I propose to anybody that can do
that that's masters of Time like that
they could predict eclipses they could
do everything
I propose to you that's a very very
Advanced Society why is the shadow of a
lunar eclipse uh that's a good question
I would really like to know that I think
this is getting to be weird because the
Earth is round right well let's
yeah and how right let's let's just say
this though I think that there must be
another object in the sky like a black
Sun I've heard it called
um that is because that's the only thing
that could be including the sun too when
we have any solar eclipse
what's coming in front of that what's
what's eclipsing the sun you know
something we can't see like we don't we
don't see something over here and then
it goes over here we just see the effect
of it as it's moving in front of the sun
I think it's that's the only explanation
I have again I I don't have all the
answers I just have a lot of questions
you know I've determined some things and
after that it's kind of like well I
don't know but the same thing with the
moon eclipse it's definitely like we're
told that the Moon is eclipsing when the
sun's on the other side of the earth and
it's the shadow of the Earth on the moon
and
okay
weird it only happens when the sun when
the moon is full by the way
and if if the moon is full and we're on
a globe the Moon is only full when the
sun's on the opposite side of the Earth
then how could it you know in other
words this that just doesn't even make
sense to me and that was one of the
first things that made me start thinking
about Flat Earth was I was like
what
the moon's doing this and we never see
the moon in the sky the full moon in the
sky this with the Sun at the same time
only when like literally if I watch when
it's going to be a full moon I can watch
the sunset over here and look in the
other direction and watch the moon rise
wow you know wow that right there just
starts putting questions into this whole
idea of a globe right off the bat like
huh
um interesting yeah so I think we can
keep it really simple like as far as
Flat Earth a lot of times people oh I
will only know that when I go up 30 000
or 60 000 feet and look down and see
that it's well okay why don't you just
recognize that one it's actually a law
water always finds its own level and
once it finds level it stays level I
mean it moves people a lot of times
people what do you mean lotion's not
flat
all right yeah it is it's sea level go
to a big lake For Heaven's Sake you know
just go to a big giant Lake you can
there's like even Lake Tahoe there's
parts of Lake Tahoe like on a map it's
just a little tiny thing but when you're
there you can't see the other side of
the you can't see the other Shore it's a
big lake you know and it's flat we all
know it's flat no no notice even think
that this lake is curving at some point
you know go to the Great Lakes Michigan
you look across and it's what you know
like one of one of them was uh 80
something miles away and on a really
clear day you can see the city over
there
same thing on Kauai you can see Oahu
it's 90 something miles away yeah that's
closest point I think it's 94 miles away
you can on a clear day you can see it
the whole thing and not just the fairy
tip you know but it's supposed to be
like if the Earth was curved and again
they know the science tells us what the
curve is That's supposed to be like two
miles below the horizon
that's not what we experience here's
another here's another part again I'm
keeping this real simple just water
being level okay if water is level then
and and or let's say if we're on a curve
what is that curve and here's some of
the math where this is when it's like
okay that's definitely not happening
science tells us that water is curving
the
um the equation is eight inches per mile
squaring the distance as it increases so
eight inches on one mile it's they
literally have the balls to say that the
Earth is curving eight inches in one
mile
none of us have ever seen that have ever
ever ever happening ever you know like
literally never like we can be right
here where we're at look across the bay
right over there and see Malibu you know
and it's like
at least 10 miles away as the crow flies
and according to science that's supposed
to be 66.6 feet below the horizon or not
below the Horizon but they're supposed
to be 66.6 feet of curvature in 10 miles
right like that's not what we see now
here's here's an interesting little
factoid
the 666 that number shows up all over
the place scientifically like in
scientific literature
hmm for example here's one of them they
tell us that our Earth is tilted okay
and they tell us 23.4 degrees
take a 90 degree angle and you and you
put it at 23.4 right if you take the
rest of that angle yeah I could just as
easily say that the Earth is tilted at
66.6 degrees
just it's if it's tilted at 23.4 so you
can also say 66.6
um we're traveling around the Sun 66 600
miles an hour a square mile is 66 666
feet or something like that feet square
feet
um
anyway there's there's like 20 of them I
could just right off the top of my head
though it's it just kind of makes it
kind of go really okay I know the Earth
is curved at 10 miles 66.6 feet really
okay just happens to be huh okay
I'm thinking that
like people go well who would do it how
could they do it
um two things I would say if like I
didn't even believe I was more of an
atheist I was agnostic before all this
happened even though I was a Christian
as a kid I very much questioned it all
tossed it out the window because of the
not because I wasn't believing things so
much it wasn't so much I was doing
research at first I became an uh energy
worker I was doing healing work and then
and to do the healing work I was doing
things at the Bible and or at least my
Christian brothers were saying that was
evil wrong that's demonic you know so I
got way away from Christianity because
the things I was doing were working you
know like if I Touch Somebody it can
actually change their need their back if
you know so I'm like hmm I'm not praying
I'm not asking God
you know like from this perspective hey
God heal this person anymore I'm like
literally like hey what's his name how
to fix it and so because I did that's my
first Escape out of religion
Christianity was because of that and
that led me more into that's how I
discovered Flat Earth was just literally
going okay you laugh at all those round
earthers totally I call you call you
Globe turds yeah 100
um and I don't I'm not really making fun
of you because it's it's really
um
I kind of feel sorry for people just
because they've that we've been taught
so so firmly that science knows what it
is you know science is right
there's so many so many deceptions in
science that I'm I'm All About because I
love I'm a scientist I like science I
love science you know it's the
scientific principle but you said after
college huh what'd you study in college
um philosophy mainly that's my main
thing
um I did English as well as that was
that was a major for a couple years
where'd you go to school
um Fresno I went to Community College
first played football at read in Reedley
College and then
um
I went to a Bible School
um did some
um anyway a lot of different trainings
in little schools not in any University
I just did a lot of yeah at that point
in my life I'm already 20 years old and
I'm like
doing more like um
yeah intense training you started
questioning
death already or conventional exactly
things exactly I'm not going to go the
conventional way yeah exactly when did
that start for you like teenager
yeah yeah I guess a lot of it happened
because of my molestation because of
because of the fact that I'm I suppose
these are people are supposed to be you
know looking out for me there's
protecting me and my parents know that
they're there you know what and they're
doing the exact opposite yeah exactly
like whoa
um and and it definitely reinforced that
everybody that idea that everybody's
lying
I didn't understand it because let me go
down that for actually for a second the
the idea that everybody was lying to me
is when I was younger
um
now that it never made sense okay ever I
didn't understand how my parents could
be lying to me because I knew there
wasn't in purpose it wasn't or
intentional it wasn't my grandpa like I
love my grandpa he never lie to me on
purpose you know he was he was adamantly
against lying loves the truth and yet I
would feel when I say he was lying or I
felt deception what I mean by that is
um I feel like we all have this but I
like to describe it as like a bell when
I'm talking to somebody and this Bell
goes off ding you know I feel like I
know when somebody's lying to me and I
think we all do you know and if you
don't it's because you're covering up
and pretending not to but if you're
sensitive and
open up a little bit spiritually you can
always tell when somebody's lying to you
and you can also tell when somebody's
telling you a radical truth like you can
feel both sides of that equation you
know like they're uncomfortable saying
this but they're going to say it anyway
and it's like I respect people like that
um and so the lies were happening I
think were in unintentional things like
my grandpa lying to me it wasn't like he
was actually lying to me it was just
that he believed things that were false
and he was pushing me to believe the
same kinds of things
but to me I'm like why would we continue
on if we all sense that that's wrong
it's just because everybody else is
doing it if that's really what that's
and that's what I'd ask my mom
especially why are they doing this mom
like what the freak she's like Well
everybody's doing it so let's just you
know in other words if you don't do it
you're going to be ostracized you're
going to be outside the circle so just
come on come back into the circle and I
realized
when when I started becoming more
spiritual
um that led me into flat earth once I
saw the Earth was flat then I started
believing in God again there has to be
something going on here because
it's too perfect you know it's too
orderly and the fact that we're being
lied about it why how you know like
respectable people now I think it's more
spiritual like in other words I don't
feel like there's there could be a small
cabal of people of men human actual
humans that would want to hurt all these
other humans you know to deceive
everybody and can try and keep them
enslaved I just don't see that like
humans could be that evil could actually
be that that twisted
but now I now I'm thinking like yeah
there is there are some humans that are
involved in this for sure I don't think
it was a human idea though I that's part
of the reason I'm more spiritual
thinking that there has to be
put it this way I didn't even start
believing in God until I believed in
demons and I felt like wow there's some
literal misrepresentation intentional
deception going on
and it's coming from the highest levels
you know
um yeah like how could that happen in
other words for example this is what I'm
this kind of how I got to that is how
can all of the pilots and all the
astronauts be in on this you know how
could everybody all the scientists be in
on the joke you know and deceiving
everybody on purpose it's not like that
it's not like that at all it's just
everyone is deceived for example I have
a good friend of mine's a pilot
and until I pointed this out to him he
just never even thought about it no
astronaut who saw who went up in space
and saw that the Earth is a flat plane
decided to speak up exactly exactly
exactly and if they do
boom they're immediately shut off
they're ridiculed or they're killed or
their family members or something bad
happens if you question reality in any
way or question the reality that they're
pushing it's not reality if you question
the reality that they're encouraging you
to believe then they shut you down
really really fast and so nowadays I
like to that's one of my keys is what
can we talk about and what can we not
talk about because if if there's things
that that people can say
and get shut down and destroy their
careers are destroyed their families are
wiped out or they're murdered or all
these mysterious things happen what are
they talking about and if they're
talking about something
that they get killed for it's like for
me I want to listen to what they're
saying because probably it's some going
to be some truth there
yeah so that's led me into getting
further and further down these rabbit
holes obviously right you know um let me
ask you a question okay one last
question what is uh what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life how old are you I'm
53 53. most important lesson
um
I would say yeah I would just say that
there is there is energy and we can
impact the energy around us we have the
potency
yeah I like to share that anytime
anybody sits down with me so I can
demonstrate feel this energy you know
not even touching you I'll just move my
hands around you you will feel it
um
and yeah I feel like if if that's the
one thing if I could just teach that
people have asked me that what would you
do if you had a billboard no it's just
any way I could
encourage people to see that because if
you can see that you that the energy is
all around you and you can impact that
energy then it empowers you you know and
that's what yeah that's why I would say
that's what I want people to believe
that's also the reason I'm talking about
Flat Earth it's not I'm not really
saying all the things I say to I'm not
just I'm not just saying it to make you
question your reality I'm saying it so
because I believe when you start
questioning your reality and you find
things that are actually true that you
can actually step on and believe and be
feel secure in then it changes your
entire perspective it changes your being
changes how you react and respond to
people since I found out the Earth was
flat I'm way more confident I trust my
my gut way more you know a lot of times
our heads can be deceived you've heard
the quote the the statement that we only
use 10 of our brain scientists now I
just heard this a couple days ago
scientists now are saying we only use
about one percent of our brain all right
well where's the rest of it that's the
part that I want to get a hold of is the
other 90 99 of the of our brain is in
our is in subconscious unconscious and
in other words our gut when when our gut
is telling us something
I believe listen to it and but we've
been taught to question that push all
that down all your feelings all your
Notions any gut feeling ah no it's not I
can't be actual that's good unless you
can put it into your into words but by
the time we put it by the time we
formulated our thoughts and then it
comes out as words that's way up here
like that's so
or that's just a such a surface thing
that there's no way that's actually
pointing to the truth you know even if
I'm coming straight from truth and I try
to hand it to you by the time I put it
into words it's not the actual truth
anymore but if that's why I like to
demonstrate to people rather than just
say words lay on the table let me move
my hands around you you're gonna get up
and you're gonna know things that you
never knew before you're going to feel
completely different
you know it's not because I'm changing
it's just because I took some scales off
of your eyes it removed some of the
obstacles to your health
and then natural that's that's what I'd
like to say also we're all gods we are
Gods the universe is revolving around
you and when you recognize that then you
can not only feel better in yourself and
be more confident but you're going to be
having more potency more power to help
other your brothers and sisters and yeah
you oh that's the other thing sometimes
people go well if you give people power
they're going to abuse it yeah I don't
think so the more power like for example
I do martial arts also and when I'm when
I'm fighting people
the less I'm thinking the less I'm in my
head the better a fighter I'm going to
be
so all the training all the practice is
in my head to my body my body in my head
and putting it together but when I'm
actually fighting I want to be to the
place of push
because my brain is way too slow if I'm
sitting here thinking about what my next
move is going to be too late that guy's
already beat me but if I'm just flowing
then not only am I going to be doing
things fast I'm going to be doing you
know a pro I'm probably going to survive
but it's going to be a lot more
beautiful it's going to be flowy it's
gonna be more fun
um same thing applies when I'm doing
anything it's basically like people talk
about being in the zone you know like
shooting baskets for example same thing
you get into that zone everything's
perfect
boom every single shot perfect that's
why I want to try to encourage people to
be so I'm all about performance
enhancement but in order to perform
better you have to get rid of the
deceptions in front of you you know if
you're believing a bunch of garbage it's
like literally you're walking around
with garbage on you that's really hard
to move and so all if we remove that
that garbage then not only is your legs
going to stop hurting you're going to be
able to walk straighter you're gonna
have more confidence and you're gonna
have you're going to be loving people
you're not going to use this new power
to hurt anybody or to deceive anybody
you literally the more I Empower people
the more they they just become better
people
you know all right yeah Apollos thank
you so much for giving your views on the
on our planet absolutely and everything
else Aloha thank you very much